hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt an meinem t-shirt könnt ihr es
wahrscheinlich schon erkennen wir machen
heute weil ihr euch alle gewünscht habt
butterbier und ich kann natürlich nicht
alleine machen wenn der ware potter hat
unter allen youtube ist natürlich hast
du schon mal butter wir getrunken
ja und wie schmeckt gut aber will kommt
bestimmt besser hin denn wir sind hier
bei ebern es kochen menezes körper wenn
es ihr natürlich ich hab natürlich
wieder ein rezept rausgesucht aber es
ein bisschen verändert und was wir für
butter bierbrauen ist mal so groß ist
richtig kelly cae schlag sahne und
butter wir braucht man natürlich noch
höher als erstes brauchen wir zurück und
machen
nicht die ganze feier wieder rausholen
bis jetzt habe ich voll gut geklappt
ja ich versuche mich zu kollabieren
mach mal mach mal so ein drittel sei das
ist einfach selber entschieden
wir sind hier beim schmeckt einfach
alles gut da so bestimmt lecker butt gar
nicht so scheint es erinnert mich an
irgendwas aber ich hab mir schon das
tschechische sowas ja ohne scham
tschechische süßigkeit ist bestimmt zur
suppe
also das ist jetzt ein bisschen
emotionale geschichte für mich aber
eigentlich wollte ich immer havelfest
sein und dann hab ich die klamotten
dürfen dort ich dachte so schätzt jetzt
muss ich jedes mal wenn ich jetzt zum
harry potter laden bin bin ich
vorgestellt
eigentlich will ich mein hafen
polizeiübergriffe
das problem kennt ihr bestimmt auch
richtig frustrierend wie würdest du
jemandem reporter erklären wenn der noch
nie etwas davon gehört haben klassische
helden reise eines jungen burschen der
auf viele konflikte trifft in einer
magischen
danke dass du dir echt jetzt kommst du
eigentlich alles rein
was ist daraus geworden
nein weil das bereite darauf geringsten
also das muss so sein das karamell hat
sich jetzt unten festgesetzt das wird
auch nie wieder ausüben top rausgeht und
das weit wie es oben drauf jetzt müssen
wir noch muss immer so tun als ob das
alles ja ich nickte ihm vorbei so jetzt
musst du noch ein halber liter ein
ganzes glas milch schreibers richtig
lecker ausnutzt während unser butterbier
jetzt schön durchzieht damit alle
geschmäcker sich so miteinander
verbinden machen wir was 70 und da haben
wir uns gedacht ja was ist wohl isu
besuch und wir glauben es ist eine
mischung aus einer sucht einen anderen
job und einer noch am konsum eine zufall
in suppe eine tomatensuppe und eine
zwiebelsuppe das sind die zutaten für
eine richtig gute zyxel zubereitung ist
so einfach wie auch einfach gemacht
zwiebel so besticken täglich aus
ich würde dann sagen wir machen einfach
die hälfte von jeder suppe in dem top
fit zu halten
ok und die letzte hälfte klar
jetzt müsst ihr die zutaten also die
drei suppen nur noch miteinander
vermischen wir müssen ist dann auch
alles probiert dafür hat mich am meisten
freue mich dass jetzt nahm werden
richtiges harry potter meist 70 politik
hilfe
nein das habe ich gerade gesagt aus doch
sieht man nicht habt ihr zuschauers
gerade geschnitten hat es muss es
schmeckt ja gar nicht scheiße
beschritten
besondere aktion wollen wir führen jetzt
das papier in unsere mutter teresa und
dafür um eine kenne das wisst ihr gut
schmeckt ein bisschen wehmut aber es ist
auch super ins platten vor allem ist
geil ist wenn man hier oben diese butter
hat blizz kinder und raumfahrt ist total
ich kann er richtig gut gemacht auch
sein
ich kann es auch gebäck
o
und darauf ist doch ein bisschen zimt
potter fans ein bisschen runter wenn man
80 das sind normale leute übernimmt ein
bisschen action sequenzen also klar
kelly wenn ich so sehe dann sieht mainz
total doof aus neben zwei bis kunst ohne
witz schaue ich das mal an wie hübsch
das aus ein bisschen zu gut für dich ja
unbedingt und er gern hier bekommst du
eine freu mich auf dieses match
stückchen ich hab noch nicht mal was
seiner mutter
sie ist das lecker also wenn ihr es
nachgemacht auf jeden fall ein foto von
instagram ich freu mich drauf man warum
sind alles jede folge besitzer geil und
kam komm ich ins bild passe flüssige
butter und rahm gemeinde habe sich aber
kaum ganz ehrlich sieht gut aus
ja gut aus würde es aussehen auch gut es
aussieht ist da kannst du dich verlieben
freunden verabschieden
welche freunde
das war's und falls euch noch andere
rezepte gerichte einfallen von film und
serien dann schreibt sie in die
kommentare
wir sehen uns dann das nicht bis dann